cbs news legal analyst ricky kleeman
joins us now for more on the written
house verdict ricky good morning let's
start we nancy referenced these two
sides here of the way people look at
this what did this come down to for the
jury to find him not guilty
the jury took their time because the
jury was concerned with the judge's
instructions and when you look at the
law in wisconsin and many other places
once the defendant says i acted in
self-defense the burden of proof is
solely on the prosecution to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that he did
not act in self defense so at that
moment in time when he is confronted
with what he says is imminent danger
that he's in fear he's going to lose his
life
then is his subjective belief i'm going
to die
is that belief reasonable well the
prosecution has to prove it was not
reasonable that's such a difficult
burden
the jury by the way had the instructions
they first asked for pages one to six
they kept those a long time they wanted
12 copies
and when you look at that that was the
self-defense instruction
then they moved to the crimes themselves
they took three and a half days this was
a long deliberation and they thought
about each charge ricky did the did the
verdict surprise you at all and if not
did anything about this what what about
this trial surprised you the most the
thing that surprised me the most was the
moment that kyle rittenhouse took the
stand i am a firm believer in the years
that i practiced that i did not want to
put my client on the witness stand
because he is then fair game for the
prosecution
on the other hand what we learned after
the verdict was that they had done focus
groups and the focus groups were with
the defendant testifying and without him
testifying the focus group showed the
defense that it was better if he
testified
kyle rittenhouse is the only person who
says that at those moments
he actually thought he was going to die
and we have to remember how brief those
moments were the first shot is less the
first four shots of rosenbaum less than
one second the next group of four shots
involving the person who dies mr huber
and the person who is struck in the arm
mr grosskrodz who pointed the gun in the
photograph at kyle rittenhouse's head so
it's not only written house's fear it's
gross christ the victim's alleged
victim's testimony that he says that
rittenhouse didn't shoot at him until he
pointed the gun at him what are the
wider implications here beyond
just the details of this particular case
what happened inside the court do you
think anything else happens right now
well i do i think that legally there is
no precedent here this case rests on its
facts before this jury but societally
people did not watch this case from
beginning to end and as a result they
continue to be polarized about gun
rights about vigilantism and certainly
about the right of self-defense all
right ricky thank you so much
do we still have time
yeah i think we're good
i really want to do i wanted to talk
about the amar arboret uh shooting death
case uh the the defense has rested
your impressions of the testimony thus
far well if you look at the amount aubry
case when you have that defendant
testify when you have one of the three
testify
and as i say i'd never like to see a
defendant testify if i'm a defense
lawyer i relish it if i'm a prosecutor
i say
that he was a disaster on the witness
stand why even in his direct examination
he is the aggressor his father is the
aggressor
they are going after a mount aubry who
only is running he says the defendant
says on the witness stand that he didn't
threaten him there was no fear
as he's chasing him he ran away from him
he ran away he answers he ran away if
there was ever a defendant who was
talking himself into a conviction and
perhaps the conviction of his father and
their neighbor it was this one yeah key
difference and is totally a lot of
people say was the prosecution in these
two cases i think that's correct um you
have a very powerful prosecutor who
knows what she's doing in uh georgia all
right ricky thank you so much